there is no good reason why a
nine-year-old girl died here
no explanation
that really makes sense
olivia
was simply at home with her family
behind their closed front door
it had gone 10 o'clock at night when her
mum cheryl heard noises outside on
king's heath avenue
the simple act of opening her front door
gave a 35 year old man outside an
opportunity
he needed somewhere to hide
a 35 year old man was being chased by a
man armed with a gun he was firing at
him
the man being chased forced his way into
olivia's house
and the offender ran in after him
firing a number of shots with complete
disregard for olivia and her family
the men had approached from the finch
lane end of king's heath avenue in
dovecot heading towards the family home
when olivia's mother opened her door to
see what was happening outside the 35
year old pushed his way into the house
the gunman followed and got his hand in
the door he then shot olivia and injured
her mother
when the gunman got in the house he
continued firing before escaping on foot
a dark-coloured audi then collected the
35-year-old man from the front of the
house taking him to hospital while
olivia lay dying in her mother's arms
her family are absolutely devastated
inconsolable and heartbroken
i know that the murder of olivia has
rocked our communities
who are quite rightly upset
and outraged that such an abhorrent
crime has occurred here on the streets
of merseyside
a random needless death
at the end of the day someone's life is
a little girl she's passed away in
horrible circumstances and if you know
what it is you've got to tell people we
need to
find these people out so it doesn't
happen again
remarkably it happened 15 years to the
day since the shooting of school boy
rhys jones in nearby crocstath an 11
year old who was caught in the crossfire
of two liverpool gangs
this too has the hallmarks of an
innocent child being drawn into the
callous world of criminal gangs through
no fault of their own from everything
the police have said here the one thing
that is clear is that olivia and her
mother did absolutely nothing wrong
[Music]
she was about to move into year five at
school at the end of last term olivia
played a munchkin on stage in the wizard
of oz
olivia was a little ray of sunshine
um
she was bubbly
she had a little heart of gold nothing
was too much trouble for her she loved
to help the teachers she was the life
and soul of the class
she's in the minds of everyone working
on this
the police need the public's help
experience tells them some may be
reluctant to come forward
there are clues to find and suspects to
arrest
right now this is an urgent major
inquiry there is a gunman still at large
tom parmenter sky news liverpool